,
EVIL INVASION KILLING OF MEN,
WOMEN, AND CHILDREN.
WE'VE SEEN IMAGES, WHICH SHOWN
THEM TO YOU ON THIS PROGRAM,
MASS GRAVES, ONE BODY BEING
TOSSED ON TOP OF ANOTHER.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS IN CHINA, NAMELY
TAIWAN.
HERE TO REACT TO THAT AND MUCH
MORE, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU KNOW, I KEEP READING THAT
YOU WANT THE U.S. TO PUT BOOTS
ON THE GROUND AND YOU TOLD ME
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT THAT, AND
I ASKED YOU AND I SAID UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES.
CAN WE GET THAT CLEARED TONIGHT?
>> YEAH, I DO NOT WANT ANY
AMERICAN BOOTS ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE, I DON'T WANT A NO-FLY
ZONE BUT IF THERE IS THE USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS BY PUTIN
AGAINST UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, I
WOULD SUPPORT A NO-FLY ZONE
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE BREAKING
EVERY WAR CRIME RULE IN THE
BOOK.
AND TO BAN ALL CHEMICAL WEAPONS
WOULD BE NOTHING IF WE DIDN'T
ACT WITH A NO-FLY ZONE BUT RIGHT
NOW NO BOOTS ON THE GROUND,
NO-FLY ZONE.
CHINA.
CHINA IS TRYING TO BAIL OUT
PUTIN.
IF PUTIN LOSES, CHINA LOSES, SO
TO THE BIDEN DEMONSTRATION,
DON'T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE WITH
CHINA YOU DID RUSSIA.
IF YOU BELIEVE THE CHINESE ARE
GOING TO HELP PUTIN SURVIVE BY
PROVIDING MILITARY QUIT BECOME
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE.
BY THE WAY, THEY BACKFILLED
THEIR CREDIT CARD PROBLEM THAT
HAPPENED WHEN MASTERCARD AND
VISA PULLED OUT OF RUSSIA.
CHINA'S CREDIT CARD SYSTEM TOOK
OVER.
PUT ON THE TABLE FOR CHINA TO
READ THE SANCTIONS THAT WILL
COME YOUR WAY IF YOU HELP PUTIN.
I WILL HELP YOU AS A REPUBLICAN,
MR. PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT BIDEN,
IF YOU WILL WRITE DOWN
SANCTIONS, SECONDARY SANCTIONS
AGAINST CHINA, WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO THE CHINESE ECONOMY IF THEY
BAIL OUT THIS WAR CRIMINAL
PUTIN.
I WILL BE YOUR BEST ALLEY IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
WRITE IT DOWN NOW SO CHINA CAN
READ IT.
BECAUSE NOBODY BELIEVES WHO IN
LESS YOU WRITE IT DOWN.
>> Sean: I'M NOT SURE IF HE
REMEMBERS YOUR NAME.
WE WATCHED LARGE BALLISTIC
MISSILE SLAM INTO OUR BASE IN
IRAQ FIRED BY IRAN.
WE GOT A WARNING THIS WEEKEND
FROM CHINA THAT THE WORST
CONSEQUENCES FOR ANY COUNTRY
THAT SUPPORTS THE TAIWAN
MILITARY AND IT SEEMS -- CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG, SENATOR, ALL
THAT BLOOD IMPROVEMENT HAS TO DO
IS MENTION OF GLARE WEAPONS,
BIOLOGICAL, CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
AND JOE BACKS OFF.
JOE VETOED THEM FROM POLAND
HIMSELF.
HE MADE THE DECISION ACCORDING
TO ALL OF THE REPORTS.
WHAT IS BIDEN WILLING TO DO IN
EVERY ONE OF THESE CASES,
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE A PRESIDENT
THAT HAS ANY TYPE OF DOCTRINE --
WHAT IS THE REAGAN DOCTRINE, THE
TRUMP DOCTRINE, THE BUSH
DOCTRINE?
WHAT IS THE BIDEN DOCTRINE?
BOW DOWN AND PRAY AND HOPE FOR
THE BEST?
>> YEAH, APPARENTLY.
SLOW AND INDECISIVE IS HIS
REACTION.
BUT HERE'S AN IDEA.
IF YOU BELIEVE ZELENSKYY KNOWS
WHAT HE'S DOING AT THE UKRAINE
PEOPLE ARE HEROIC AND THE
EFFORTS TO PROTECT THEIR COUNTRY
FROM A RUSSIA INVASION, GIVE
THEM WHAT THEY SAY THEY NEED.
I'M NOT ASKING FOR BOOTS ON THE
GROUND, I'M NOT ASKING FOR A
NO-FLY ZONE, BUT I SPOKE TO THE
UKRAINIAN AMBASSADOR AT LENGTH
TODAY AND HERE'S WHAT SHE TOLD
ME.
THEY CAN FIGHT ON THE GROUND,
THEY ARE HOLDING THEIR OWN ON
THE GROUND.
THEY DESPERATELY NEED SOME HELP
TO CONTROL THEIR SKIES.
THEY WANT THEM.
THEY BELIEVE IF THEY HAD THEM,
THEY COULD REALLY PUSH BACK
AGAINST THE AIRPOWER OF RUSSIA.
>> Sean: SENATOR, HANG ON A
SECOND.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: WE ARE GIVING THEM
JAVELINS, STINGER MISSILES, WHY
CAN'T WE GIVE AN APPROVAL FOR
FIGHTER JETS?
WHY NOT?
>> WELCOME HERE'S HERE'S WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS, THAT'S AN
OFFENSIVE WEAPON.
HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE WORRIED
ABOUT GIVING THE UKRAINIANS THE
ABILITY TO GO ON OFFENSE?
THIS IDEA THEY WILL TAKE THE
SQUADRON OF THEM AND INVADE
RUSSIA, UKRAINE WE DO THAT, IS
STUPID AND CRAZY AND IT'S JUST A
REASON TO DENY THEM THE HELP
THAT THEY WANT BECAUSE BIDEN IS
AFRAID OF PUTIN.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
IT WAS OKAY FOR POLAND TO GIVE
THEM, WE WERE GOING TO GREEN
LIGHT IT.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE PUTIN AND
ADMINISTRATION, THE PUTIN
GOVERNMENT A BIDEN SAID IF YOU
DO THAT, ALL BETS ARE OFF AND WE
FOLDED LIKE A CHEAP SUIT.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
HELP THE UKRAINIANS WITH
REASONABLE REQUESTS, GIVE THEM
THE MAKES, GIVE THEM THE AIR
DEFENSIVE ABILITIES THEY DON'T
HAVE AND IF YOU CAN NEUTRALIZE
OR LEETS LEVEL OUT -- VICTORY
FOR UKRAINE IS MY MESSAGE HERE